negli episodi precedenti diritto michael
rady fuggire prendi lo farà gli spara di
sparatutto
lotti turisti in realtà questo
all'interno dell'eu ronnie dopo
mafalda guarda ho anch'io
madonna c'è mica un tizio col collo
allungato in reception no vabbè
potevo andare perché sono dovuto passare
all'interno lista scuola potevo andare
da un'altra parte qualsiasi minchia gli
scacchi giochiamo 1 v1 zii e avrei
giocato volentieri anche a scacchi e non
so però
stavo scherzando allora credo che io
debba trovare la testa di tutti i pezzi
ne vedo uno li posso prendere il pezzo
prestito questo cuore tanto la misura
più thank you
e proprio la regina degli scacchi adesso
ci penso che la corona in testa ma sei
vivo sei morto questa cosa non la
capisco è che ce ne sa ci camon ce l'ho
fatta ragazzo è stato molto più semplice
del previsto non è vero ciao risolto ma
che per queste paper in giro la prendo
ti chiamerò osvaldo grazie l'osvaldo
presso un cane che pisciano esserci
dietro la sedia l'ho visto adesso poi il
mio amico osvaldo siamo due compagni
eros me lo porto cosa me ne faccio di
una chiave che non ho capito
l'ho trovato la chiave a caso a c'era
una porta che chiusa a chi a ok capire
osvaldo tipo joan attimo che devo aprire
no non fate mai mio amico osvaldo me lo
porto in giro tutto gioco ragazzi è il
mio migliore amico lo voglio no ragazzi
lo devo lasciare indietro per forza
perché adesso usare questo come scala ti
prego provare arrampicarti e seguimi
perché non ho idea di come fare se no
con lo porto sono posto è purtroppo
ragazzi vanno così le cose al giorno
d'oggi piace si conosce poi ci si lascia
un casino ti do una mestolata in bocca
che minchia ti rialzi mango aver sbaglio
venite qua ragazzini meno tutti eccolo
ancora cava sono il re della giungla
e va beh questo colucci questo match
incredibile ragazzi mi porto al mestolo
che cacchio è successo qui cosa state
facendo
cosa fai tu laggiù no raga travestimento
top del stealth del mondo ragazzino
veramente un genio fighissimo ma che
idea pazzesca come diavolo benvenuta
ciao ragazzi sono uno di voi e non mi
spinge a è brutto schifoso l'aido
aggrappa nova però è bellissima sta roba
effettivamente siete un po
indisciplinati non so che cosa me lo fa
pensare però dovreste fare tutti un po
di bon ton e af testa di minchia e non
mi spinge c'è uno c'è un tizio legato
robbie preparate con il fondo cosa
diavolo è cos'è qual è il problema
ragazzi ma che cacchio va insegnato
l'educazione porca vacca piega misseri
sta beccando roma peccato ciao
ammazzatevi tra di voi
questi sono i più tranquilli no ragazzi
non si fanno le cose non si stacca la
testa a comp
no ragazzi ma che cosa diavolo sto
vedendo dove avete messo mafalda porca
vacca dove ce l'avete dove me l'avete
messa ecco se notate stato non debba un
travestimento c'avevi zio l'hai perso
ecco cappello
abbiamo perso mafalda in tutto sto
casino però va beh mafalda non è non è
più spuntata da un ora quindi non so
effettivamente dove sia finita mai
provare a usare dei cose di vetro come
piedistalli ricordate a yes lo porto che
lo porta non si sa mai
c'è un cervello molle
[Musica]
sta qua è ovunque
ciao ragazzi adesso ho capito perchè sei
così severa c'era un motivo non mettere
le rane dentro il barattolo che tanto
non se l'è mai a nessuno potrei sbirri
certi sotto la gonna una protezione anti
piazzare il fatto non c'è niente di
terrore capitano non mi ha visto e
dategli da perfetto perfetto io ci vado
sono andato io sono andato ne sbatto non
so neanche dove cosa sto facendo non lo
so quindi vai da un'altra parte non di
là da qualsiasi altra parte porco
demonio qualsiasi madonna salvato in una
maniera incredibile
ok cosa scrivi non c'è nessuno adesso
per la porto sicuro non aperta mamma mia
ragazzi che il giocatore che il
giocatore signori sono morto no morire
così sarebbe stato ridicolo prove let's
go è il martellino del favi poolside e
non me l'aspettavo
ciao a tutti i morti ce l'ho fatta credo
e non lo so se sono tutti
se provate alla vicina arrivi schianto
al martello in tap hales rosi
madonna ragazzi incredibile sono a terra
è troppo divertente che play col
martello comunque questo non lo posso
tirare la maestra perché sono è troppo
grossa
spero lo farei ma che cazzo fai timori
madonna raga quanta gente stoffa fuori
nostro cosa luthor c'è veramente un
martello è un'arma di trappole perché
non le vedo le trappole ogni volta
mannaggia c'è una tegola che più alta
delle altre no
mafalda schifosi laiche arrivo via il
martello piana tello piero pero che
l'itis in tetro con la faccia che si
ritrova a piedi vieni qua
venite qua schifosi pezze provate
un'altra volta prendermi per il culo o
no i ddos
ragazzi miei mafalda che cavaliere che
c'hai e devo capire come legarti che qua
ma c'era aspetta col pastello proprio
mafalda redditi leciti e non so cosa
perché mafalda tutto a posto
mafalda mafalda dimmi che sei viva ma
fatevi va a posto
meno male tutto è bene quel che finisce
con una falda per terra che non si sa
come il diavolo fa sopravvissuta
sono stato ho fatto un disastro per
arrivare qua fatto fuori c'era una
maestra non ho fatto i compiti un casino
l'importante è che tu sia arrivati a
mamma mia ragazzi che disastro fatto per
arrivare qua dammi la mano vieni qua
grazie madonna raga per riprenderla
mappa della mia mano anche se ci
passiamo 18 tranquillamente lec ce
l'abbiamo fatta raga fuori da questa
scuola nelle palle con gli insegnanti
più brutti della storia
ma cosa ma dove sono un bambino come
faccio mafalda oggi non andar là sotto e
che poi un casino so neanche perché sto
facendo questa cosa dipende
ora ho capito se lo ritiri su
teoricamente dovrebbe essersi aperto il
piano falda che fai
anzi perrotta strafare ok halloween
spingero che spingiamo bye bye bye bye
eccolo
[Musica]
monotoni monotonia no come siete
simpatici amico mio
la smettiamo di dar fastidio questo
piano e ti butto giù questa è così
riesci a 621 mai mettitelo da sola non
c'ho voglia come damon a potevamo salire
così anche prima allora davina mano va
che non si appresta a fare è 20 volte
più forte di me ma fa un cazzo se fate
caso ci fate caso sempre lei che mi
spinge su che sono quello debole del
gruppo
non so come ho fatto a salvarla ho fatto
fuori tutti quanti non so come mamma mia
vi prego basta basta a mentre suona devo
fare le cose raga figata metto c'è il
ponte mentre suona e non se ne accorge
ragazzi bellissimo 9 gen e ancora oggi
denti 21 giu bravo
bravi ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta vai
vai vai vai ce l'ha fatta e basta fine
devo andare anch'io poi l'isola frazione
ci sono prove di sopra ce l'abbiamo
fatta ragazzi ci ho messo due ore tanto
non mi ha i nomi figlia sono nè il tool
più aspettiamo che sony
[Musica]
ok mafalda by è il momento bellissimo
sì sì tanto ormai porca [ __ ] vice pg16
madonna garanzia vai vai vai che ci
arriva ci arriva ci arriva non so come
ma ci arriva minchia non me l'aspettavo
mai che potesse entrare qua sotto
basta non c'è noi abbiamo come farlo e
possibile si è intrufolata fino a 4 ma
quanto c'era il lungo stop collo eccola
ce l'ho fatta beh può arrivare anche qua
allora è infatti ci arriva no ragazzi
pazzesco
incredibile era la stessa di prima
comunque la fine va al cuore ma
veramente quando le hai scoperto che i
condotti sono il tuo punto sicuro il tuo
luogo dove non ti possono attaccare 9
quando ti becchi poi qualcuno
liberamente tra pinter cure come ho
fatto io adesso madonna che è presa male
lega la madonna incredibile let's go fa
da ce l'abbiamo fatta siamo usciti
adesso siamo veramente usciti dalla
scuola dopo tutto sto casino gravati
figo no comunque allora se mi posso
permettere
fino ad ora secondo me fino ad ora è
meglio del primo
ma molto match è veramente incredibile
mano una regia che non cioè non so
veramente descriverlo ragazzi cioè bello
come inside non meno e la cosa è
veramente pazzesca cioè non solo pensare
quanto ci abbiamo messo la parola
piaccia sono sti bambini finti fantasma
stack staff a questa sembra la faccia la
metto qua come inizio guarda che va
sotto non si può mettere peccato sarebbe
stato un bel riferimento con una cm
quindi
c'è un po di infiltrazione però un
cappello c'è un cappello lo cos'è
l'impermeabile perfetto adesso sei come
little light nessuno uguale colori
autentici che l'it e lei nessuno se non
sbaglio era così il personaggio
vorrei dire a cagata sembravano quello
di te non so dove sia una finestra ci
entro
me ne sbatto a ho finito ufficialmente
la parte della scuola che è perfetto se
mi ha dato via cimenti istruito perché è
finita
cos'è questo è un ospedale guardi manca
guardi bene in meglio guarda pensiamo
questo è ancora più tetro l'ospedale
proprio non si no vabbè ragazzi minchia
questo è ancora veramente molto più
magro ma manca però cosa stanno dicendo
macro propri g la zia
c'era una volta un ospedale ora ci sono
solo i letti a castello sul niente
fin qua mi sembra abbastanza chiaro cosa
dobbiamo fabra va la zia che iniziativa
brava la zia let's go
[Musica]
comunque tutto a posto raga una torcia
perfetto lander man official game
adesso no vabbè ragazzi adesso horror
puro quindi cosa prevedi per usarla
torcia
ragazzi figli la ragazzi ebrei che
atmosfera da paura bellissimo da paura
nel senso di figo però è anche
effettivamente da paura ora che ci penso
ed andiamo possiamo andare di qua no
ragazzi fatevi controllare un attimo
perché troppo bello c'è una gamba di
legno o soliti a [ __ ] ok cosa prenderlo
questo lo sa bene della gamba di legno
almeno no non si piglia va bene madonna
che atmosfera pazzesca
io non seguirei proprio il sangue se
dovesse vincere però se proprio dobbiamo
una voglio voglio una soda grazie
schiacciavamo tasto
non è buio la coperta cui la c'è la tv
ci penso io ci penso io posso vedere
barbara d'urso volendo o switch area
uomini e donne a mio piacimento faccio
io vedo nessuno che un po messo male da
sinistra e non so se avete visto vai
sintonizziamoci non ho capito cosa sta
porta effettivamente mi ricorda qualcosa
del primo lite nightmares però non mi
ricordo per bene c'è l'asta porta ad uno
sbaglio
ok
ragazzi ma che ma che tra macha sto
gioco 20 ininterpretabile sono quasi
arrivato alla porta
chiudi quella porta va là chi di quella
porta via mette che fa apposta tokyo
maledetto questo saltare pure yes c'ero
quasi arrivato sasha
sì però mafalda non mi stare vicino
quando facesse cose sennò rischi che è
tipo samara esco dal televisore che fai
ti cade addosso gli è colpa mia
allora abbiamo subito un ascensore però
servono due bobine che non abbiamo
l'ascensore è utilizzabile secondo voi
ok c'è un ma cosa c'è un orsacchiotto
che ho dentro una chiave lì sul muro la
cose che fate esperimenti sugli ossa
chiotti cos'è sta roba
baci mafalda che fini co
non avevo anch'io aspetta ei fa che
miglio ton sur da serve perché devo
prendere sicuramente qualcosa metterlo
lì qualcosa mi dice l'orsacchiotto non
so cosa il sito che sto guardando cosa
c'è dentro che non è che disposti tutti
i segni tv mentre fai giochi contro di
martino ecco lo vedi che c'e la chiave
quello dobbiamo prende quella quello
quello la posa sta roba
non serve quello che tu serve quello che
ho io c'è una chiave qua ho capito vuoi
farmi di vuoi dirmi che dobbiamo doveva
prima trovare il 2 spaccarlo per fare
lascia per aprire il l'orsacchiotto che
non avevo capito allora non hai fatto
bene a fare sta roba non ero io stupido
ora che ho la chiave ragazzi non ho
veramente compresa cosa vi serva ma
vabbè l'importante averla
non ce l'ha portali chiusa
beni che c'era il trucco mannaggia non
avevo visto neanche io proprio io avevo
preso la chiave a caso lo scotto del nec
surround questa roba
mi chiamo questo è un ospedale ragazze
con tutto rispetto
c'è veramente troppo macabro e il 15
dove sto andando
ci sono le bobine per aprire l'ascensore
qualcuno me lo spiega mystical zona non
è possibile tutto questo non lo è aiuto
c'è una mano che si muove via e non ci
credo sono mali che si muovono tana
pugno buongiorno più serve cosa devo
fare qua c'è una mano che mi aspetta
nell'ombra a turista do vista maledetta
che faccio sono come i ragni che schifo
veramente perché devo fare visita a chi
pensa che mi fai pena per il culo alla
mano io faccio pigliare per il culo da
un altro via dove devo andare
non ci arriverò mai alla grata per
l'anno di carmelo dico pure ok
vai alla grata non ci arriverò mai ci
sono arrivato non ci servono picardi tu
perché poi schifo non è vero
ciao scherzato talk e salotti prenderò
epifanico charivari comunque vale sono
otto ma preso già fatta non ci posso
credere
quindi non passa più o meno male ragazzi
madonna che ansia
l'ho presa la bovina e ma prima delle
pratica chi cioè soldi e non ce la posso
fare a fare indietro sulla bobina come
faccio
cioè con la bobina in mano
dal lancio prima da lancio e non posso
spiegarmi con quale criterio come faccio
come potrei mai o la schiaccio prima ma
non so come tema non possono forse sì
forse sì forse sì è una porta chiusa
porca [ __ ] eh vabbè lo schiaffo sonoro
che ho fatto sono un genio ma c'è il
martello ma non l'avevo visto proprio io
ma [ __ ]
non ci credo l'ho presa fuori è morta e
mori porco demonio anno muore non può
morire
ok è morta è morta e morte morte porta
via via via via via via mola il martello
è morta è morta adesso posso fare ci
passo ce l'ho fatta credo madonna
incredibile ci sono volute tre botte e
pensava non morire mai
e stai calmo devi stare calmo zio la
passava la martellata quel punto ci
passano che ci fa superforza diving
addio che alzi a ragazzo è stato
possibile veramente mai più contro le
mani cosa fai mafalda non si staccano i
pezzi degli arti alla gente va beh lei
si diverte che dobbiamo fare lo metti tu
tasse olitica senti eh io vorrei mettere
questo affare
occhio che questo di sveglia c'è anche
prima questo
altro giro altra bobina led che ormai
brothers so neanche dove si trovi stop
no ma basta allora che o ci buttiamo si
no
che bello allora ma fa damiri però è
durata poco starà buongiorno alla visco
non si muova che qua al casinò è non si
muova che ci sono degli arti per terra
la scompongo anche a lei
tutto visto minuti che fa i pezzi di no
no ragazzino sto capendo aiuto ma cos'è
aiuto noi lama tontina devi stare fermo
devi stare fermo devi stare fermo se ti
muovi ti ammazzo ti ammazzo ti faccio ti
ho preso dei martelli ho spaccato crani
per molto meno
stai fermo d'or è vero mai nella vita
che devi muoverti stai fermo è però se
tg devi andare il fratello di rick a
minare mentre lo punti capito ice chiusa
la porta non può passare o che ha posto
no mi chiama che anzi regalo a tourist
oculate è inutile che fate gli sbruffoni
qualche un casino
no ragazzi orribile starò e quindi
l'urto cosa devo fare qui dove devo
andare
poi c'è una porta quindi niente andiamo
di quanto non mi piace questa cosa delle
cose che si muovono le persone che si
muovono state fermi per l'amore di gesù
grazie e vabbè quanta gente che cacchio
rave party cos'è sto assembramento quale
era settete ora michele gammino verso
ragazzi stavolta ce l'ho fatta però non
ho capito come salire fermo
come si sa le qua non ci arrivo a
famiglia e allora devi stare fermo
i ragazzi concludo qui l'episodio di
oggi manichini hanno sempre fatto paura
ma questi un po di più perché
effettivamente tutta quest'ansia
potrebbero anche non mettercela però fa
niente spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
continueranno nel prossimo stanno
succedendo cose incredibili e ci
pigliamo martedì prossimi episodi non
mancate iscritti al canale ha lasciato
un bel mi piace e non ci diamo come
sempre al prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]